Also ich möchte alle diejenigen ansprechen,
die sich eine andere Politik in Deutschland wünschen,
die sich wünschen,
dass man von seinem Einkommen
als Arbeitnehmer Leben kann,
die sich aber auch wünschen,
dass unser unser industrieller Mittelstand
nicht kaputt gemacht wird,
das kleine und mittlere Unternehmen
gute Rahmenbedingungen haben
und da is ja in Deutschland sehr viel im Argen.
Wir haben 1 Fachkräftemangel,
der vor allem
mit einem wirklich schlechten Bildungssystem
zu tun hat. Wir haben eine marode Infrastruktur,
weil über Jahre zu wenig investiert wurde.
Wir haben grade jetzt massiv steigende Energiepreise,
weil keine andere Regierung der Welt
auf so unkluge und selbstschädigende Weise
die Sanktionen umsetzt
wie ausgerechnet die deutsche Regierung.
Und all das sind
wirklich drängende Probleme und ich finde
die müssen gelöst werden und auch dafür treten wir an.